i'm john naba our correspondent berg at
mars in london berget good morning the
legal battle to extradite wikileaks
founder julian assange continues why is
this case back in court
well this is yet another court hearing
and a really extraordinarily long legal
battle that stretches back
over a decade so the u.s is now
appealing against the decision that a
lower uk court had made in the beginning
of the year where the lower court had
argued that julian assange should not be
facing extradition to the years because
of his mental state and now the u.s are
appealing they want him in the u.s and
they want to put him
in a court in the u.s and try him there
yeah so what are the possible outcomes
now for julian assange where could he
end up
well the the question for the court is
now
was the district court that had judged
that julian assange's mental state
he was not fit enough to face
extradition to the u.s so they could
uphold this verdict or they could
obviously come to a different conclusion
now the us has now put in some
assurances they have said that he would
not face the worst form and the most
mentally mentally scarring form of
solitary confinement if he were to be
extradited to the us also they opened up
the possibility of him possibly
transferring to a prison
to his native australia so these are new
um implications for the court here in in
the uk and they have to
make another ruling
on on all this new evidence that the uk
has the u.s has presented
so mental health is part of the
background here burger what do we know
about assange's condition
well we know that he basically was in
confinement now for over a decade so
whenever we see new images of him he
makes the appearance of a man who's
really fading away his supporters are
saying that he seemed very unwell and
very thin uh when he appeared via video
link in this latest hearing his partner
was speaking outside the court and she
said that there is um that he
is suffering from a depressive disorder
and she even said that there was a
political conspiracy to kill him so his
supporters and also his lawyers arguing
that the uh threat to his mental health
is real
burger birkenmars in london thank you